in this video I want to introduce you to
some terminology that will be useful in
our discussion of functions and
invertibility and this is in general
terminology that you'll probably see in
your mathematical careers so let's say I
have a function f and it is a mapping
from the set X to the set Y and we've
drawn this diagram many times but it
never hurts to draw it again so that is
my set X or my domain and then this is
the set Y over here or the codomain
remember the codomain is the set that
you're mapping to you don't necessarily
have to map to every element of the set
or none of the elements in the set this
is just all the elements the set that
you might map a element in your codomain
to so let's see if I have some element
there f will map it to some element in Y
in my co domain in my co domain so the
first idea or or term I want to
introduce you to is the idea of a
function being surjective surjective and
sometimes this is called on two on two
and a function is surjective or onto if
for every every element in your
co-domain
so let me write it this way if for every
every let's say Y that is a member of my
co domain there exists there exists
that's the that's the little shorthand
notation for exists there exists at
least one at least one at least one X
that's a member of X such that and I can
write such that like that actually let
me just write the word out such that
such that f of X f of X is equal to Y so
it's essentially saying look you can
pick any Y here and every Y here is
being mapped to by at least one of the
X's over here so for exam
both actually let me draw a simpler
example instead of drawing these blurbs
let's say that I have a set Y that
literally looks like this let's say that
a set Y I'll draw it very and let's say
it has 4 elements it has the elements a
B C and D this is my set Y right there
now let's say my set X my set X looks
like that and let's say it has the
elements I don't know 1 2 3 & 4
now in order for my function f to be
surjective or onto it means that every
one of these guys have to be able to be
mapped to so what does that mean what
does that mean so if every one of these
guys let me just draw some examples
let's say that this guy maps to that
let's say that this guy maps to that
let's say that this guy maps to that and
let's say let me draw a fifth one right
here let's say that both of these guys
right here map to D so F of 4 is D and F
of 5 is D this is an example of a
surjective function so these are the
mappings of F right here this function
right here is on 2 is on 2 or surjective
why is that because every element here
is being mapped to now let me give you
an example of a function that is not
surjective let me add some more elements
to Y let's say element Y has another
element here called e now all of a
sudden this is not surjective not not
surjective and why is that because
there's some element in Y that is not
being mapped to so if something if I
tell you that F is a surjective function
it means that if you take essentially if
you map all of these values everything
here is being mapped to by at least one
element here so you could have it you
know it could everything could be kind
of a one-to-one mapping and I'll define
that a little bit better in the future
so it could just be like that and like
that and you could even have it's at
least one so you could even have two
things
here mapping to one thing in here but
the main requirement is that everything
here does get mapped to another way to
think about it is is that if you take
the image the image so surjective
function let me write this here
let's objective function well let me
write it this way so if I say that f is
surjective or on to these are equivalent
terms that means that the image the
image of f remember the image was all of
the values that F actually maps to so
that means that the image of F is equal
to Y is equal to Y now we learn before
you know your image doesn't have to
equal your codomain but if your you have
a surjective or an onto function your
image is going to equal your codomain
everything in your codomain gets mapped
to and actually another word for image
is range you could also say that your
range of F is equal to Y remember the
difference and I drew this distinction
when we first talked about functions the
distinction between a co domain and a
range a co domain is the set that you
can map to you don't have to map to
everything the range is a subset of your
Co domain a range is a subset of Co
domain of your code may that you
actually do map to if you were to
evaluate the function at all of these
points the points that you actually
mapped to is your range and that's also
called your image and we use the image
the word images use more in a linear
algebra context but if your image or
your range is equal to your codomain if
everything in your codomain does get
mapped to then you're dealing with a
surjective function or an onto function
now the next term i want to introduce
you to is the idea of an injective
function injective injective injective
function and this is sometimes called a
1 one-to-one function so let me draw my
domain and codomain again
so let's say that that is my domain and
this is my co domain so this is X and
this is y if I say that f is injective f
is injective or one-to-one that implies
that for every value that is mapped to
so let me write it this way for every
value that is mapped to so let's say
I'll write it I'll say it a couple of
different ways there is at most one X
that maps to it there's at most one X
that maps to it or another way to say is
that any for any Y that's a member of Y
let me write it this way for any Y that
is a member of Y there is at most there
is at most one at most let me write most
in capital at most one X such that such
that f of X is equal to Y there might be
no X's in map to it so for example you
could have a little a member of Y right
here that just never gets mapped to you
know everyone else in Y gets mapped to
but that guy never gets mapped to so
this would be a case where we don't have
a surjective function this is not on two
because this guy is not he's a member of
the co domain but he's not a member of
the image or the range he doesn't get
mapped to but this would still be an
injective function as long as every
every X gets mapped to you a unique Y
now how can the function not be
injective or one-to-one and I think you
get the idea when someone says
one-to-one well if two x's if two X's
here get mapped to the same Y or 3 get
mapped to the same Y this would mean
that we are not dealing not dealing with
an injective or a one-to-one function
injective function so that's all it
means let me draw another example here
so if I take let's actually go back to
this example right here when I added
this a here we said this is not
surjective anymore because every one of
these guys is not being
apt to is this an injective function
well no because I have five F of 5 and F
of for both map to D so this is what
breaks it's one to oneness or it's
injective nough sits surjective nasai
wanted to make this a surjective and an
injective function i would delete that
mapping and I would change F of five to
be e now everything is one-to-one I
don't have to the function I don't have
the mapping from two elements of X going
to the same element of Y anymore and
everything in Y now gets mapped to so
this is both on 2 & 1 2 1